Lu is in Chicago
i Liu how are you better than I should
be Dave come are you the same how can I
help
well I have a 14 year old daughter in
high school and listen to her she is the
last remaining 14 year old and the
planet without a smartphone and she
wants one desperately and while we could
we could afford it it would not be
wouldn't that be a hardship we have been
following you and we just got our hands
on the book he wrote with your with your
daughter but I was I wanted to hear what
you had to say about how we could have
her pursue some sort of savings towards
this she's she's a good kid and she is
involved in a lot of giving type clubs
at school and I don't want to discourage
that just to make money to buy a phone
you understand so I but I do want her to
have a sense of earning there you're
right there's four things you can do
with money and our job as parents is to
make sure the kids can do all four work
save spend wisely and give she's good at
giving she's probably not afraid of work
no and so it's okay to balance the
giving with the saving in order to do
some wise spending so it sounds like
there's an opportunity for some lessons
here which is what I'm always looking
for I'm not as worried about the actual
purchase because you could afford it you
can try checking by the finaland phone
right but is there an opportunity to
create a lesson here and it's something
she's highly motivated to do so maybe we
do a matching plan we say when you save
up this amount while maintaining some
giving while maintaining wise spending
then I'll match that and we'll do the
phone could you expand on that just a
little yeah put a price does she earn
any money doing anything actually she
just that's what you mentioned that just
in the last week she got an idea making
these little brace
and then she's been getting about five
bucks each from seems like a number of
her friends uh how is she doing how is
she doing giving them you know that
would be Lackey well I thought you said
I was in a giving Club at school
that's what time oh okay yeah so alright
let's get her working was she doing
chores at the house I don't know what
she's doing but let's get some kind of
income flowing in it doesn't have to be
a big deal and you can match her
three-to-one and so she saves up $200
you put the other six hundred dollars
with it or something like that and get
the $800 phone if that's what it is I
don't know which phone you're looking at
but something like that and have her
give some and have her spend some